[Applause]
straightaway that's good at this but
Nikki's going to give them an extra
fortune
[Music]
the why has 34 an aggressive
the wide nose if he comes off a screen
they're double-teaming so turn down the
screen and go dunk on whoever's in the
paint that was a big-time play by
big-time player Brian I'll tell you what
that every once in a while pascale short
and a long rebound take it down Brooklyn
here we go spike sees me
[Applause]
see I can win three blocks
[Music]
[Applause]
so what's up LeBron here please show us
that again that's a little bit of
Dominique off one leg he used to double
pump it bring it down this is the new
style an excellent look at it from our
incredible crew here in Dallas
[Applause]
[Music]
3oz merits at the end of the day you've
given up 54 points with nine minutes ago
in a second
you gotta find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity Barbara
Davis
this Technic he's going to give them an
extra fortune
[Applause]
well I tell you AG is showing off of it
but that is making
LeBron the eldeen RL look at that
[Music]
Walker will dance
[Applause]
whoo big shots by the Celtics at the end
of the first and second quarter
ruggedness the Ison is a tough matchup
for vercetti does the best he can but
get the waka muscle-bound with a dive
off the ball on the weak side Chris
bowling ball
takes it away ahead for heel back for
Yatta Yatta side of the combo and George
Hill beautiful basketball first the
great defensive play give me that cp3
get it early get it back watch that
bounce pass though look number from
George Hill to then get out the way yet
backboard swinging Monster Jam me bug I
am is still in that place able to come
up with inside and be a tease deep
[Applause]
[Music]
almost didn't think he would get it off
the file there
on the lake region
we live in his best light bounce to give
both in the penalties under two to play
hard step back puts up the three got
head
James Harden double team got a chance
for a four-point play straight paces
here by James Harden
Debra trying to get organized
offensively Morristown
[Applause]
that's what folks this is a plus you
don't get any better than this
right between the late oh here we go off
the glass and in
[Music]
man just an idle beautiful
one on one move there what up at you boy
Adam left codes you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from great report